est-ce que vous parlez à sept
changements climatiques à l'école
vraiment nombreux l'on peut simplement
vous pourrez fois l'épreuve a paris
cependant perdu pour passer pour qu'il
faudrait d'après moi vraiment sujet
important plus
la génération qui est sur les bancs
d'école actuellement on va trouver des
solutions aux problèmes gigantesques
complexes qui sont entraînés par le
réchauffement planétaire le plus
réactive des derniers millions d'années
on dit souvent que pour s'attaquer à la
racine du problème il faut miser sur
l'éducation meilleur fossé immense entre
ce que les élèves apprennent en classe à
propos de l'environnement et l'état
actuel de leur planète
ce que vous avez à propos de changement
climatique ça vient d'où de nos parents
surtout des réseaux sociaux dans les
articles de journaux aux abois comme ce
maxi papa ci a trouvé pour vraiment
chercher pour retrouver plus de 300
euros ce que ces jeunes rapportent il ya
des études qui confirme même parmi les
meilleures provinces les politiques en
éducation s'attarde minimalement au
changement climatique
l'enseignement des changements
climatiques est inégal à travers le pays
et les notions en environnement varient
d'une province à l'autre d'une école à
l'autre et même souvent d'une classe à
l'autre si la crise climatique c'est
l'enjeu de ce siècle si le lieu de
formation de jeunes citoyens c'est
l'école ben ça me semble qu'en vingt
spéciales qu'on en parle essentiellement
dans les médias ou à l'extérieur de
l'école je comprends que le regard sur
ce thème actuel est sévère je l' ai moi
aussi ce regard sévère l'appeler jeunes
réclament une éducation relative à
l'environnement ça paraît quelque chose
qui allume de plus en plus les élèves
étaient punir l'année puis d'aborder vos
dons par les testeurs c'est décevant
pour la fraude en poudre 90 % des
québécois de 12 à 18 ans seraient
préoccupés par les changements
climatiques à travers le monde c'est 70%
des jeunes qui qualifie la ravenelle
d'effrayant ça m'inquiète ça m'inquiète
sérieusement on est vraiment vraiment
foutu sion manger pendant les prochaines
nuits les prochains mois les prochaines
années pour les futures générations et
des générations présentes d'être
vraiment envie d'élever des enfants
sachant qu' il repose une belle qualité
de vie possible après c'est risque
c'est pas parce que l'environnement est
pratiquement absent des programmes qui
ce fait rien dans les écoles il ya
énormément d'adultes et d'élèves qui
font tout pour que ça change pour que
l'école sa basse elle aussi en apprenant
à nos jeunes a à g et avoir confiance en
leurs attentes
[Musique]
il ya des milliers d'autobus jaunes qui
parcourent des routes comme celle chaque
jour de la semaine partout au pays cette
route là nous mène à l'école paul
germain ostiguy ou p.geo pour les
intimes
[Musique]
visiter une école secondaire s'est aussi
retourné dans ses souvenirs les bons
comme les moins bons
il ya souvent des visages qui nous
viennent en tête des personnes qui ont
peut-être changé notre vie en donnant
tout ce qu'elles ont pour transformer
une école comme les autres en un lieu
extraordinaire et j'ai aussi une école
qui est située dans une région rurale on
a plusieurs élèves qui vivent dans des
milieux où les parents s'occupent de
ferme
l'environnement ce serait peut-être une
pop et être ce serait important qu'il
fasse partie de certains cursus de cours
pour que nos jeunes soient réellement
sensibilisés ils ne le savent peut-être
pas maintenant les élèves mais dans
quelques années dans quelques décennies
ce seront les décideurs de demain je
convaincu qu ils vont avoir un impact
dans leur milieu à eux dans leur famille
dans leur maison
[Musique]
moi je sens un groupe de musique j'aime
jozi le plein de sujets avec les élèves
l'environnement ça fait partie
de cette semaine leur présentait une
vidéo d'un pays sous développés où les
enfants aller chercher des matériaux
dans les dépotoirs pour se fabriquer des
instruments de musique que je demandais
à mes élèves qu'est ce que vous voyez en
regardant cette vidéo le valérie est
loin d'être la seule personne à prendre
une initiative pour ajouter un peu
d'environnement dans son école à chaque
année le jour de l'attaquant qui
revenons en sortez dehors qu'on allait
ramasser les déchets soient courtes n'a
comme planté des tournesols et des
haricots on a fait un friperie avec
toute l'école ça me rappelle pas de bons
souvenirs oui ça ressemble pas mal à ce
qu'on faisait dans les écoles ya trente
ans les jeunes se préoccupe de plus en
plus de l'environnement il faut dire que
l'école les informe davantage et que des
projets concrets voit le jour maintenant
mais le milieu écologique qui est
inquiet quand même parce qu'ils aident
pas encore de véritable politique sur
l'éducation et l'environnement
sans les épaulettes et avec une image en
haute définition ce bulletin leur ait pu
passer pour une actualité les constats
restent les mêmes on n'est pas vraiment
craindre et c'est vraiment pur mains des
initiatives personnelles les
enseignantes et les enseignants
d'aujourd'hui nous on dit ça aussi on
s'en passait une certaine relation super
importante mais est-ce qu'on peut encore
se contenter d'un plus ça change plus
c'est pareil vraiment c'est finalement
c'est la voie que je te monte l'eau
comme ça dans toutes les classes
[Musique]
c'est impossible de creuser sujet
l'heure sans s'offrir une petite jasette
chez lucie sauvé après une longue
carrière de plus de 30 ans de recherche
on peut dire que c'est la grande
pionnière de l'éducation relative à
l'environnement au québec et les
retraités maintenant mais il est resté
très actif et sa mémoire est précieuse
[Musique]
le québec était le leader dans la
francophonie internationale en matière
d'éducation relative à l'environnement
en avait au québec
le service d'éducation relative à
l'environnement rattaché ou nous faire
de l'environnement mais en
95-96 est arrivé le grand virage vert
d'éducation au développement durable
de sorte que ces structures noah on
espère
pour faire une histoire très courte en
1992 lieu le sommet de la terre à rio
qui a fédéré la planète entière autour
de l'objectif commun de développement
durable on voulait allier l'économie et
l'écologie plutôt que de les opposer et
on a considéré à ce moment là que parler
seulement d'environnement devenait
désuète mais les jeunes n'ont pas
attendu que l'école les y invite pour se
mobiliser
à ce moment précis on s'est interrompue
par un essaim d'abeilles qui se cherche
une nouvelle ruche si c'est pas le
symbole d'une nouvelle génération qui
veut s'affranchir je sais pas trop ce
que c'est il faut pas avoir pas
[Applaudissements]
so grande de voir
l'engagement des jeunes donné beaucoup
d'espoir et d'énergie à plein de gens
dont dominique d'hinnin c'est lui seul
depuis une vingtaine d'années il
travaille dans le milieu scolaire et ils
cherchent un moyen d'amener plus
d'environnement dans les écoles en 2018
il le mobiliser le monde de l'éducation
du québec et a lancé un des projets les
plus prometteurs pour amener les écoles
un peu plus loin le lab 22
cette toute petite équipe a une grande
mission sur les épaules aider les écoles
à être plus éco-responsable et apprendre
aux jeunes à transformer leur communauté
rien moins
une fois vous arrivez dans l'école c'est
pas le même modèle un kit de départ clé
en main on vous commencez à composter
puis vous faites de recyclage est
souvent les écoles veulent qu'on
commence tout de suite à dire qu'ils ont
peu de s'attaquer des jours d chez nous
on leur dicter un processus pour nous
c'est hyper important c'est un projet
démocratique aussi donc on implique les
élèves les parents les membres du
personnel et la direction dans la
définition du plan d'action donc qu'est
ce qui est prioritaire selon heureux et
ensuite donné un objectif sur trois
quatre cinq dix ans le plus value du lab
c'est aussi de faire une analyse
environnementale rigoureuse donc on fait
un diagnostic et tout de suite après on
se met à l'action et on travaille sur
les différents axes pour faire en sorte
qu'ils aient des changements terrain et
développer son autonomie chez les cols
ces trois ans avec 3 millions $ en poche
le lendemain deux voeux accompagnent une
cinquantaine d'écoles québécoises soit
environ 10% des établissements du québec
ça va toucher presque cent mille jeunes
une des écoles qui fait partie de la
première corde du projet fait pge qui
vient tout juste d'amorcer le travail
avec le label dit on en a nommé
quelques-uns des types de pollution mais
qu'est ce que vous pensez que vous
pouvez faire c'est quoi le contrôle que
vous avez sur ça moi je fais partie du
comité environnement en partenariat avec
le label de en fait c'est le comité la
22e donc de cette façon là je me sens
intégré de l'environnement dans mon
travail pas juste à l'intérieur de mes
cours le but ultime c'est d'amener
l'environnement comme une valeur
principale dans la tête des jeunes dans
la tête des enseignants dans la taille
du personnel
personnellement j'essaye vraiment un
impact sur moi ça m'a ramené du thym
premièrement pour réfléchir au sujet
avec des gens mon milieu mais ça m'a
mené aussi des ressources puis de fil en
aiguille moi même j'ai élargi ma
compréhension de tous les enjeux par
rapport à l'environnement je prends
conscience aussi de ce qu'on peut faire
comme milieu scolaire pour sensibiliser
pour informer savoir que dans le futur
que je vais pouvoir dire moi et moi j'ai
rendu mon école la plus verte ça se
fondent infosys montpellier
c'est le gouvernement du québec qui
financent principalement le lap 22 mai
l'argent vient pas du ministère de
l'éducation
la subvention a été donné dans le cadre
du plan d'action jeunesse 2021 2024 nous
autres comme ici à pg où on parle
peut-être un petit peu à l'envers on
part d'une initiative locale d'une
association avec le lap 22e mais c'est
évident que s'il y avait un message qui
provenait d'en haut ce serait plus
facile d'engager le personnel mais aussi
les élèves dans une démarche comme celle
le problème c'est que ça repose sur une
personne qui lève la main qui dit mais
moi ça me tente de faire ça
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous pensez que vos propres
salles touadéra propos des changements
climatiques où ils sont outillés sur têt
trop petit en parle mais y'en a qui on
parle pas du tout je lui parle juste de
leur mentir ça ferait vraiment les selon
les convictions personnelles des
professeurs eux ils vont nous en parler
sur la fréquence et ça les passionne
on est au collège jean eudes j'ai
rencontré david rousseau qui est un prof
de sciences au secondaire il est aussi
conseiller pédagogique en environnement
séisme
c'est notre superbe au centre de tri aux
magnans place ouais c'est là que ça se
passe mais faut comprendre que pour un
jeune entre 12 et 17 ans la gestion des
déchets ça d'avenir comme son premier
pouvoir d'action ouais et qu'on essaie
de bien le faire
agent il ya déjà plusieurs projets
écologiques en marche notamment grâce à
david et à des élèves qui s'impliquent
dans des comités et grâce à l'équipe du
lab 22 qui les accompagnent aussi
celles auxquelles je
[Musique]
peux dire que j'ai eu du temps collège
privé mais même les meilleures
conditions font pas disparaître tous les
obstacles est ce que dans la matière que
vous avez enseigné aux élèves ya de
l'environnement c'est assez flou et il
ya des éléments c'est écrit noir sur
blanc mais c'est l'enseignant qui va
décider qu est-ce qui a envie de faire
comment ils ont envie de le faire donc
les gens suivent leur passion moi ce que
je pense qu'il est important de mettre
en lumière c'est que c'est facile de
contourner ces choses là donc quelqu'un
qui serait pas intéressé par les
questions environnementales
il peut passer très vite là dessus
[Musique]
en 2022 les élèves de secondaire iv ont
eu à répondre à 25 questions à choix de
réponses dans leurs examens du ministère
en tiens tu y en avait seulement deux
qui étaient liés à l'environnement je
les ai lus qui s étaient vraiment
faciles et aucun enseignant qui a été
formé pour enseigner présentement les
changements climatiques mais aucun os
former les enseignants pour pouvoir
former les jeunes comme on fait
présentement avec les les autochtones
content de faire des formations partout
sur roxy la diversité sexuelle il ya
plein d'informations qui s'offrent mais
je comprends pas pourquoi jamais
l'environnement est mis de l'avant
c'est énormément d'heures donc je parle
presque de bénévolat à quelques parle
parce que c'est en plus de toute
l'attention qu'on a à faire alors en
tant qu'équipe mais on a décidé qu'on y
allait notre moteur c'est c'est le
résultat c'est de voir les élèves
content de venir voir leur propre petite
plante à chaque jour c'est est-ce que ça
a poussé
comment ministère devrait s'y prendre
pour instaurer ce changement ça prend
des objectifs clairs la dernière fois
qu'on a mis en place des objectifs
c'était au début des années 2000 je
pense qu'il faut lire travailler faut
former les nouveaux profs je pense qu'il
faut peut-être changer un peu les
évaluations du ministère pour mettre des
objectifs plus en lien que
l'environnement moi ce que j'aimerais
réellement ce qu'est une petite partie
liée à l'environnement dans l'ensemble
des co je pense que ça serait important
d'en parler dès le plus jeune âge plus
le personnel veut plus et 2 il faut
commencer par saint jean puis je pense
qu'ici je rajouterais un élément de
cours un peu plus psychologique pour
savoir comment gérer son écot excité ou
des choses comme ça pour que parce qu'il
ya quand même beaucoup de poids qui mise
sur les épaules des jeunes de la société
face à l'environnement que la crise
climatique ça semble être des gros
changements pour un ministère oui parce
qu'on a le choix c'est un plus c'est
aussi le moi je trouve qu'on n'a pas le
choix on est rendu là on va vers ça nos
élèves nous le demande je pense que
c'est lui qui pousse le poke cette
transformation la ait lieu
tous les gens à qui j'ai parlé ont des
très bonnes idées mais il ya un constat
qui reste si les programmes du ministère
de l'éducation change peu on n'ira pas
plus loin ça c'est les bureaux du
ministre de l'éducation
j'espère que quelqu'un là dedans qu'il
faut pour répondre à mes questions
[Musique]
bonjour c'est reber bonjour bienvenue
dans mon bureau pourriez vous décrire
quelle est la place de l'environnement
et des changements climatiques dans les
programmes scolaires au québec dans les
programmes scolaires on couvre ce via je
dirais les cours de sciences c'est très
peu couverts comme tel ça dépend
beaucoup le tenue professionnelle des
enseignants y en a qui peuvent le
creuser davantage donc je vous dirais
que ça peut être très bien fait où ça
peut être survolées donc c'est vraiment
jouer mais très variable ou marron se
passe pour ce qu'on veut changer les
choses ah oui à partir de septembre
prochain d'ailleurs on implante le
nouveau cours culture et société
québécoise et dans le nouveau qu il y
ait vraiment prévu d'avoir des notions
d'éco citoyenneté ton que ça va être
carrément dans le cursus dans le
programme on implante un projet pilote
en septembre prochain donc ça sera plus
à jouer est très variable tous les
élèves vont avoir des notions avec ce
nouveau coup et donc il y aura une plus
grande uniformité
[Musique]
dans ce nouveau cours qui remplace
éthique et culture religieuse il ya une
dizaine de thèmes qui sont abordés ou
secondaire l'éco citoyenneté en fait pas
partie aux primaires sur quinze thèmes y
en a trois qui sont liées à
l'environnement mais on parle de
quelques heures au fil de tout le
parcours scolaire
est-ce que vous pensez que ça va être à
fait je pense que oui enfin le cours de
culture et citoyenneté québécoise va
amener ce thème là d'une manière
différente avec une perspective éthique
une perspective critique qui va
mobiliser les jeunes
l'environnement le rapport à
l'environnement le rapport au monde
c'est pas un thème parmi ces sept autres
thèmes qu'on va intégrer dans une grille
horaire d'un cours par exemple c'est
beaucoup beaucoup trop limité je pense
que il faut y penser dans une
perspective de transversalité avec les
différentes dimensions de l'éducation à
l'environnement qui sont à la fois
d'ordre affectif d'autres étaient si
j'enseigne l'environnement c'est
clairement cours de science mais si
j'enseigne l'éducation relative à
l'environnement ou où la relation que
j'ai à l'environnement c'est que je vais
pas me gêner pour réinsérer des émotions
d
dans le but crypte est un réseau de
valeur chez les jeunes
l'instauration d'une politique nationale
d'éducation en matière d'environnement
et d'éco citoyenneté c'est un levier
essentiel pour que cela pue fait
intégrer dans la formation des
enseignants et puis ensuite dans les
curriculum scolaire et je pense que
maintenant il faut se tourner vers des
initiatives à l'international forte
intéressante pour y trouver des exemples
de politiques nationales
ça c'est quand même surprenant il ya des
pays comme la colombie ou l'argentine
qui ont inclus le droit à l'éducation à
l'environnement dans leurs lois il ya
aussi la france et l'italie qui offre
des co obligatoire aux profs autant que
pour les élèves en environnement donc il
ya certains pays qui ont de la vence
mais c'est loin d'être parfait presque
tous les pays obtienne une mauvaise note
pour cette matière d'ailleurs l'unesco
préconise de faire une place importante
à l'éducation à l'environnement dans
tous les programmes scolaires d'ici 2025
mais en fait on n'a même pas besoin
d'aller voir ailleurs pour s'inspirer on
en a eu une d'une stratégie québécoise
pour l'éducation à l'environnement sur
papier du moins c'est lui se sauver
qu'il a élaborée avec plein de
partenaires des universités québécoises
parce que cette expertise le hong lei
malgré tout la stratégie a été présenté
aux élus en 2019 en fait conduit très
bel accueil à cette proposition de
stratégie là tous les partis de
l'opposition étaient saufs le parti au
pouvoir
une feuille de route c'est un livre vert
c'est vraiment appuyé par la science
comment ça se fait que ce mode d'emploi
est écarté a parlé pris en compte au nom
et pour écarter ces faux en et en
actions on est comme je vous dis on est
en train de changer des programmes c'est
peu fréquent changer des programmes
alors déjà il trouve ça normal tout à
coup on ne fait deux dans le terreau du
vendôme et c c'est atypique d'être aussi
proactive pour changer les choses les
documents qu'on reçoit deux chercheurs
de grands penseurs sont considérés sont
intégrés dans nos stratégies c'est sûr
qu'il ya des gestes forts qui vont être
porte qui ont imposé encore davantage
prennent plus loin
heureusement je pense que notre
génération est prête à faire des
changements
j'espère que ça va continuer à travers
le temps j'espère qu'on va peut finir
par se dire comme nos parents ça va être
la prochaine génération de nous sauver
[Musique]
quand on parle d'environnement ça
devrait pas être aussi parler de
solidarité de parler d'espoir puis ça
devrait donner accès à quelque chose de
plus beau qui contribuent au bien être
[Musique]
ce serait de réfléchir qu'est ce qu'on
souhaiterait que un jeune qui quittent
l'école secondaire est écrit comme
bagage de connaissances et de
compétences pour être capable de devenir
un bon citoyen avec une connaissance
élargie une connaissance générale de
plusieurs enjeux qui est capable d'actes
et convenablement dans la société et
joue son rôle
de sue et pour notre système d'éducation
ce serait qu'on se met à l'écouté des
jeunes les jeunes tripping à la porte de
la vraie vie on les considère trop
souvent comme des futurs citoyens alors
qu'ils sont déjà citoyens de leur monde
leur seule demande
à carbonne on aime vraiment soulevé chez
moi je suis curieuse de vous entendre
sur cette question là écrivez nous un
commentaire ou envoyer un courriel
[Musique]